now there's one more error in this code
but it's tricky to catch and it's tricky
because the JavaScript engine of most
browsers won't catch it either let's
take a look at that for a second now if
you go back up to the top here you might
notice that there's no semicolon at the
end of this aunt dot update statement
technically JavaScript requires
semicolons here but the JavaScript
engines in most browsers will actually
fix this for you that is javascript is
designed so that when it encounters in
error it will automatically insert a
semicolon in an attempt to fix that
error in this case it would fix it just
fine the JavaScript engine would
continue executing your code as if
nothing had happened don't rely on this
though this can get you in to problems
for example this is a single line if
statement let's say we didn't bother
with these braces here and now let's say
there is an error somewhere in this code
so that the JavaScript engine
automatically inserted semicolon well if
it inserted a semicolon right here then
this would be interpreted as an empty if
block so this statement below would
actually not be part of the if statement
and would get called all the time which
probably isn't what you want to happen
be careful about this make sure to add
semi-colons at the end of your
statements